governor abbott has just lifted the
mandatory mask mandate in the entire
state of texas
now businesses are back at 100 capacity
so when there's a giant spike in our
country
you're going to know exactly who to
blame you can say don't mess with texas
all you want you know who can mess with
texas
the wrath of god viruses don't care
about your weird state pride get over it
did the spike happen
nope it did not also i i have a feeling
this may be uh one of the only times
this person uses god unironically it's
funny how the left will always talk
about the wrath of god when all they
really mean is the sort of pagan concept
in which nature punishes you for not
being left-wing enough this is
healthy behavior oh my god other people
aren't going to be mandated to wear
masks post the possibility of
vaccination and you get a vaccine
anytime you want anybody can get one and
i can't boss people around
god will avenge himself on texas the
most religious people are the pagan
atheists